das werden sie nicht bestreiten vonen
das ist eine Regierungskrise das ist
keine Regierungskrise nein nein wer das
jetzt Moment was ist den dann was ist es
dann was ist es dann die Situation ist
die dass die die Bundesregierung die
ampelregierung auf der Grundlage von
diesen Sondervermögen eben auch an dem
Klima und transformationsfond dem
Wirtschafts und stabilisierungsfond ihre
Politik organisiert hat neben dem
Haushalt der Haushalt der für die
normalen Ausgaben zuständig ist der WSF
eine Krisenbewältigung der KTF eben für
die
die die Transformation steckt ja schon
im wortm und jetzt erkennen muss dass
das Bundesverfassungsgericht präzisiert
in in Bezug auf die Schuldenbremse dass
diese Vorgehensweise nicht okay
ist